♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute, and I'll show you
how Google Cloud Public Datasets
can add value to your analytics
and AI initiatives.
With over 200 datasets
representing more than
20 petabytes of data,
the Public Datasets program hosts
all types of in-demand data,
from convenient geographic and census data
to high impact datasets for COVID-19,
to weather and climate data
from providers like NOAA.
The best part is that the procurement,
pipeline building
and maintenance, and hosting,
is all taken care of,
so you can dive straight into enriching
your analyses or AI projects.
To get started,
head to the Marketplace
in the Google Cloud console,
where you can explore all the datasets,
their metadata, and see example queries.
Once you found a dataset
you're interested in,
click to view the dataset
where you can start analyzing it
alongside your own data.
If you're new to BigQuery,
check out the BigQuery sandbox,
which includes 1 terabyte
of querying free each month
without needing a credit card.
So next time you're looking to strengthen
your analytics and drive new insights,
take a look at Google Cloud
Public Datasets.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/public-datasets